vous voulez je réponds à les aider parce
que moi je suis déjà saoul alors voici
viviane montée qui lie
c'est finalement télé qui oui mais
indignée parce que j'y vais prendre mon
verre de champagne
ah oui on allait aller chercher les
liens je n'en attendais parce que moi je
sors ma bulle je peux pas fonctionner
ben oui c'est normal
comment ça va bien vous incarnez
mistinguett
oui j'ai c'est un don il s'appelle
mistinguett la dernière revue c'est une
comédie musicale de franklin le naour et
jérôme savary à l'opéra comique oui
jusqu'au 12 mai alors je racontais un
petit peu l'histoire l'action vous
voulez je réponds à les aider que moi je
suis déjà saoul alors je maîtrise il ya
une heure alors j'ai bricolé en
attendant
lui tout seul alors l'action se déroule
dans la loge de la missa il ya jean marc
thibault qui incarne léon volterra le
patron du casino de paris
y'a rien et steene l'habilleuse qui est
jouée par gignac
voilà et vous fait évidemment
mistinguett donc alors sur l'argument
habituel de ce genre de revues 1 c'est
comment sauver la recette quoi hein
voilà alors mistinguett si on veut la
raconter je crois qu'il ya vraiment une
une phrase formidable de léon volterra
qui raconte très bien mistinguett c'est
à cause de toi la ministre la moitié des
autruches d'australie se promène le cul
à l'air voilà donc ce serait que ça
fonctionne et c'est pourtant voilà
quelqu'un d'autre qui d'autre que vous
pouvez incarner mister you sad
l'économiste hague est venu mais j'étais
tout petit il leur était plus avant oui
mais moi j'ai rencontré une fois chez
henri varna en 1949 on a déjeuné
ensemble
mais oui amputation attendez je vous dis
à tous derrière toi je vous fais un
compliment quand on est quand même beau
quand on est vieux bien aujourd'hui mais
bien entendu
est ce que parce qu'on peut dire votre
âge 68 ans
j'en ai plus 68 ans mesdames messieurs
non gérés par rapport à mr guette
j'avais le même amour de la scène et
même c'est votre seul amour là c'est
justement vous avez donné votre scène
c'est mon mari mon amant c'est tout
c'est un peu comme nadia
mais c'est vrai parce que moi j'ai
jamais été mariée je serai jamais parce
que je me suis marié à la scène oui et
je trouve que la scène ne triche pas et
ne fait pas l'amour avec d'autres
personnes
oui et puis surtout vous vend du canal
mais elle a un mari le fait oui
ah bon je sais pas je n'ai jamais eu
mais alors vous dites je suis comme
mistinguett
quand je descends les escaliers je suis
la plus belle des femmes
oui c'est vrai le grand escalier pour
vous ces voix là oui mais je me trouve
ne cesse de m'étonner soit pas les
escaliers je me trouve quand même la
plus belle toute façon il faut pas avoir
peur de la comparaison j'ai pas j'ai pas
de crainte à avoir parce que toute façon
tout ce cru que de mistinguett summer
non c'est pas vrai parce qu'il ya
dziadosz de ses boys qui vient et j'ai
vu un petit bug qui est venu à bon ok ce
qu'il a dit il a dit vous me rappelez
tellement le mi5 vous me rappelez
mistinguett mais en tellement mieux avec
auxerre
[Musique]
oui bah
aïe
que je casse
le chinatown et je me débats y est
auj
[Musique]
m
c'est
les caisses en europe
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs
et
sortie
génial montérégie
allo
savary bonjour alors extraordinaire elle
est formidable zgela même m'a même
dureté qu'elle a une exigence dans le
travail que la miss a oui la même
discipline en souvient de votre passage
aux folies bergère mais si les gens
parlent encore quand on est sur une
scène il faut avoir le respect de ces
scènes et moi je ne supporte pas quand
les gens n'ont pas le respecte
un autre point commun avec elle si vous
êtes un peu radine quant à moi je suis
très radine
oui parce que j'aime comme donne tout
voilà je n'aime pas à payer les shows
les niçois et vous savez d'ailleurs
pendant des années on m'appelait le
professionnel guest
oui l'invité professionnelle voilà
j'étais à lutter partout dans des
maisons superbe je payais jamais rien et
j'adorerais ça gicle et à paris on peut
le dire dans un en 1932 d'un père
italien peintre d'une mère française me
dise elle travaille chez jacques fath
nous et primes au premier cours de danse
à l'âge de 8 ans avec pierre du prêt
était danseur étoile à l'opéra quand
même voilà et vous avez réussi votre
concours du conservatoire sur la scène
de l'opéra comique vous vous retrouvez
aujourd'hui avec savary pour faire donc
cette revue sur mister gay la boucle est
bouclée les jardins piscines a book
ça vous inquiète pas ce nom pour que la
boucle soit bouclée non parce qu'il ya
différents ronds dans la bonne langue
celle là est bouclée mais jean que
d'autres qui ne sont pas encore beaucoup
j'ai chaud ce soir c'est tout les choses
soient toujours en 49 vos premiers pas
au music hall de paris donc avec varna
qui voient en vous la nouvelle la
nouvelle miss target et là vous partez
pourra vous partez je ne pars pas là je
sais roland petit on est parti avec
roland petit jésus sillage était la
rivale de ses six chambres pour tous
zizi partie de l excuser moi en 49 ème
étape l'usagé que vous y officielle à
dix ans de plus si bon marché vous dire
que moi je suis parti en amérique parce
que le ballet est parti le bal est parti
à new york que nous avons dansé au
broadway theater et là il ya un monsieur
dans la salle qui était monsieur john à
haussmann qui était d'un grand
producteur à mgm qui avait ma petite
tronche adorable à l'époque et qui m'a
dit mais vous voulez venir à hollywood
faire un test et je dis oui pourquoi pas
et j'ai eu un contrat de sept ans à
hollywood quand j'avais 20 ans quand
roland petit vous a choisi pour être là
la croqueuse de diamants
ça va lui faire plaisir et zizi
jeanmaire quand même quand il m'a choisi
je vais essayer de répondre à votre
personne ici c'est exact quand il m'a
choisi c'est simplement parce que
j'étais la meilleure d'accord est-ce que
c'est exact non
ensemble à l'époque tâche est ce que
vous savez pas j'ai remis la sécu le
jour où roland petit a choisi
liliane et dans les toilettes elle
chantait vous étiez assistant on peut le
dire oui en principe je m'assois oui et
vous chantiez elle est passée devant la
porte et il a entendu cette voix
merveilleuse dans les toilettes il a dit
c'est qui cette fille oui hein
et là dessus j'ai besoin d'une danseuse
qui sait chanter qui sache chanter parce
que je voudrais remonter la croqueuse de
diamants et c'est comme ça que j'ai eu
la croqueuse de diamants mais qui est
allé à bretenoux et tout ça la coupe moi
c'est à cause de roland quand même on
n'a pas de grandes affinités tous les
deux mais c'est encourageant mais à
cause de lui que ma carrière commencée
voilà cagoule et tous ces choses qui me
sens toutes ces choses et vous avez
donné nom mettant des lignes allemand
télé qui a joué dans des 10 de l'anglais
avec fred astaire quand même
devrais je joue au tennis avec lui je
jouais au au volley ball avec gene kelly
j'allais à la chasse au canard avec leur
geybels et alors
ces scénarii genre des joueurs avec
elvis presley dans le king créole quand
même ces cellules mervyn king faire avec
brando avec monty clift dans le young
lines dmitrik vous avez fait des
créanciers vous dira hier à l'acteur
studio montgomery clift m'a emmené la
première fois l'acteur studio je suis
devenu un membre de l'acteur studio et
marilyn monroe venait c'était à l'époque
où elles venaient
pourquoi vous êtes une icône gay aux
états unis pour cause des votants
délégué mais j'ai des amis gay dans le
monde entier
mais pourquoi parce que j'ai jamais été
mariée je suis lesbienne
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas ça j'aime bien pourquoi
c'est si beau métier votre carrière et
globus votre carrière métier tellement
tellement désirable que tout que tous
les mecs se jeter sur vous oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai et donc j'en ai encore
des bleus je me disais que je n'y ai pas
ça et c'est énervant
en fait je faisais fréquenter les
homosexuels parce que les hétéros vous
sautez dessus il faut dire la vérité non
mais c'est pas ça parce qu'ils sont
souvent très drôles ils sont beaucoup
d'esprits moi je les aime et me laisse
tranquille maintenant tout le monde le
laisse tranquille ça n'a rien à voir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux